seriously posting from campus i'm not  worried it's like you want to get shut  down  hey bayview  school is back in session  and you know what that means  so am i  this week i'll be taking down four of  bayview's biggest defenders  let's just say  i've got enough dirt to bury them  your obsession with other people's lives  is pathetic  nobody at this school would call out for  anything if it weren't for me  simon  jesus he's allergic i think he's  breathing you want to help  wheeler has a couple questions wasn't it  an accident  they think one of us did without simon  you get to be valedictorian you're  accusing me now  i know that i don't know you  we need to work together now and why  should we trust you  [Music]  so you guys have no secrets  [Music]  i've got too much on the line  tell them the truth it's not going to  change anything  everybody here hated him  [Music]  but who also hated us  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  what is a secret worth literally killing  foreign  you